president Trump's decision to fire FBI
director James Comey stunned Washington
and his sending shockwave through the
agency president Trump's in a letter to
comb his office late yesterday
dismissing him he told the director
quote it is essential that we find new
leadership James Comey was in Los
Angeles he was actually speaking to FBI
agents when he learned of his dismissal
the White House says the Attorney
General and his deputy both recommended
Comey be fired for mishandling the
Hillary Clinton email investigation now
critics questioned the timing on that
and asked what it could mean now for the
investigation into Russian election
meddling Margaret Brennan is at the
White House with the uproar over commis
a ouster Margaret good morning good
morning well the president has the power
to dismiss the FBI director for any
reason and yesterday he found one former
director Comey learned of his fate from
television reports trailed by TV cameras
former FBI director Comey cut short his
Los Angeles visit after learning of his
sudden firing official notice was
delivered via email and a letter
hand-delivered to FBI headquarters by
president Trump's longtime personal aide
Keith Schiller in it the president said
he accepted recommendations for commis
dismissal by his Attorney General and
Deputy Attorney General writing quote
you are hereby terminated and removed
from office effective immediately
the president also referred to the
ongoing FBI investigation into whether
members of his campaign colluded with
Russia quote while I greatly appreciate
you informing me on three separate
occasions that I am not under
investigation I nevertheless concur with
the judgment of the Department of
Justice that you are not able to
effectively lead the bureau White House
deputy spokesperson Sarah Sanders
insisted the firing was unrelated any
investigation that would have been
taking place would continue to take
place
she said the Justice Department had lost
faith in the FBI director due to his
handling of the investigation of former
secretary Hillary Clinton's emails tell
me what you would do would you speak or
would you conceal in a two and a half
page memo dated yesterday Deputy
Attorney General Rod Rosenstein argued
quote the FBI's reputation and
credibility have suffered substantial
damage and almost everyone agrees that
the director made serious mistakes no
reasonable prosecutor would bring such a
case Rosenstein faulted Comey for his
July announcement that the Clinton case
should be closed without prosecution he
also disputed commis characterization of
why he reopened that same case just 11
days before the election but during that
time then Senator Jeff Sessions and then
candidate Trump praised Comey FBI
director Comey did the right thing when
he found new evidence he had no choice
and it took guts for director Comey to
make the move that he made shortly after
his election mr. Trump told 60 minutes
that he had not determined whether Comey
would serve the rest of his six and a
half year term are you going to ask for
his resignation I think that I would
rather not comment on that yet I don't I
haven't made up my mind I respect him a
lot
I respect the FBI a lot two months later
the president warmly embraced him and
announced that Comey would stay on White
House staff was here well into the night
and we're told the search for commis
replacement has begun Charlie the only
event on the president's public schedule
is a closed-door meeting with Russia's
top diplomat Sergey Lavrov he is the
highest-ranking Kremlin official to
visit the White House since inauguration
thanks Margaret